[Music]
so mouthing oh that's a nice mouthfeel
yeah I should warn you that is not from
our wonderful coffee sponsor black rifle
coffee this is actually drop or trickle
and that's because I went to a coffee
shop recently when they they gave you
this press oh they gave you this as like
a palate cleanser and so I drink my
coffee before the show oh my Shelly
cleanse and we have Dan crunch on the
show today yes looking forward to that
that'll be a lot of fun I cut you off
just but you seem like it's okay you can
talk with me no I am talking I said I
loved him
oh this is I'll say it again I love you
order black carrots I'm wonderful but I
cannot I cannot deal with Gerald
Morgan's pirate fetish in the morning
hey we might get a call from YouTube
about that yeah another was referring to
as a pirate hey and I really appreciate
the kind words from yesterday's show to
everyone out there but you can stop with
them because I'm not a homosexual so a
mug Florentine is a hash tag of course
we're doing this through the end of the
month the final show will be next
Thursday where we watch a press briefing
Thursday night live and live fact check
CNN oh boy ah so right now the promo
code is quarantine you get $30 off if
you join it a lot Oh is kind of that
come slash mug Club subscribe to the
podcast all that stuff everywhere
podcasts are sold are not sold okay
given away we have a lot o of course in
your chat you can chat with us yeah if
you're a mug club member and we'll bring
up the chat a little bit later audio
wait looks panicked or we know he's
going really well
I'm always banished so I should warn you
health I amount of very angry this
morning yes very
I wanted to do the CNN fact check now
the room with my wife under warning in
my you know office and have a TV and I'm
watching I watch on Hulu I watched it
and because I have to and I assume that
they don't get the ratings from Hulu I
don't know if I could sit hope yeah
there's a way to make into a movie
theater without paying but doing it with
television programming I would do it
right that's what we can do it to that
number with every Michael Moore film I
would be like I don't know I'll pay too
blade three I don't care paid your money
issue it then I but then I was on record
paying for blade three I said I hope no
one gets my time I guess it's better
because as an actor it was a write-off
all right you spent $200 on blade three
big and let me ask you though question
do you think that the Cuomo family is
the perfect example of celebrity
privilege and everything that is wrong
with this country because we will be
talking about Cristina Cuomo that is
Chris Cuomo his wife and of course we
don't want to cross any boundaries
because she has her own health blog has
nothing to do with the fact that she is
Chris Cuomo's wife so I want to make no
absolutely the bounds of propriety yeah
I don't know if a propriety minute was
like proprietary mmm I think those are
different words but I was so mad this
morning that I was in my office watching
and I'm not sure who CNN my wife came in
and they were saying there was someone
on CNN saying do not please a medical
professional drink or inject Lysol or
bleach as the president prescribed babe
I love you yeah I am not mad with you or
mad at you but right now I really feel
and I'm I mean this the urge to wit my
mug at the television screen so I think
you should leave the room yeah and then
I hit the heavy bag for like 30 minutes
then you know get rid of the energy and
I can I tell you I was reading this this
morning and I had to stop reading
because I you know I started reading the
reports when I was on the crapper and it
from going he got like literally no
because I read it and I thought oh my
gosh he must have said some terrible
things and of course you're reading the
articles over and over again and you're
like where's the actual quote take one
word and then they add you know to the
beginning of the yes so then you have a
dig and he got a day couldn't find her
on CNN so then I'm like digging more and
I'm like alright where's the actual
transcript they just give me the
paragraph give my full sentence yeah and
then I read the sentence and realized
holy crap they're not even trying to be
honest no it's pretty absurd this is CBD
so don't give me crap oh my god I can we
get like the heavy bag in here for you
next week when we do the Thursday show
okay
we're gonna need a stress reliever for
you in the middle of that for our mess
hey gerald can we do it I hope that is
not FDA approved because that's not so
you don't know we haven't been following
of course we'll get to this in a second
where they're blaming Donald Trump for
even implying that you should be
drinking or injecting Clorox Lysol
name-brand products all of it yeah I'd
like to do named brain it'd be like if
Donald Trump said there are certain
grains and cereals that they're funny
right now might have antibodies and they
go unlike the president we do not
believe that specifically General Mills
products cure Cove in nineteen the big G
you do not in fact gotta have your pops
will not according to the FDA and make
it happen
sack to you homosexual Anderson Cooper
live from your firehouse that you
repurposed for five million dollars in
the West oh wow you walkin taint a white
ghost terrible host guy quality of the
insults improve
that's not exactly a cipher I'd want to
put a highlight reel that was pretty bit
all right well I won't enter the fray
Your Honor I rest my case
yeah just give me a give me a loss give
me a guilty verdict I've handcuffed all
right so let's kind of walk through but
before we get to the Lysol and bleach
and thank you guys so much for watching
tuning in we love spending the morning
with you we're doing more this as we go
forward so the Trump presser yesterday
brought good news we didn't stream it I
almost want to just string them every
day now but I know we can he was back to
views back to kicking reporters asses
and really as all by delivering good
news which they didn't want to hear so
turns out like we've been talking about
sunlight high temperatures and high
humidity actually does in fact kill the
corona virus we are the President and
people tuning into these briefings they
want to get information
and guidance and want to know what to do
they're not looking for a gig I'm the
president and your fake news I'll say to
you that's a very nice throne above me I
know you will because I know the guy I
see what he writes he's a total faker
you ready you ready it's just a
suggestion back from a brilliant lab by
a very very smart
perhaps brilliant man this proper half
son here how can about heat and you see
the numbers so that's it that's all I
have I'm just here to present talent I'm
here to present my field because we want
ideas to get rid of this thing and if he
is good and if sunlight is good that's a
great thing as far as I'm concerned go
ahead but what I love with Donald Trump
is when he says perhaps brilliant I'm
just presenting Talent what he's saying
is you are an antonym yes talent no
brilliant gape of catfish faker and your
boy Fred fakes yet I love it I do like
how he he just is like very you know
remedial with them yeah yeah just so you
know that's a smart person yeah now let
me reiterate there's talent exactly and
the funny thing is to like he has acted
again we've done these press briefings
he has experts there most of these
quotes from Donald Trump's medical
experts come from the briefings yeah
because he goes out gives a general
layout of what it is they'll be
discussing and then they make sure to
fine-tune it correct it because anyone
can get things wrong when you're dealing
with the met what did I have to have you
google this morning and you know that I
glutathione yeah glutathione cause like
I've read about this for a long time you
do drink remind you take connect we've
talked about it's what they give you
when you go to the hospital and you have
some kind of a semi tiffin toxicity it's
a medical tool let's use it you can also
purchase as a supplement creates loose
glutathione and your but I've never
actually heard it pronounced I've only
read about it right
so I misspeak and I'm sure but I'd also
dumber than Donald Trump let's right if
you were Donald Trump you didn't like
accused of like prescribing some drug
made in South America right evil like
that's illegal
no they probably have some stuff that's
pretty good you should open up the
border okay you know the hunger owns are
making great strides in the medical
field folks you know more
regimen we don't know about I just you
know I just buy my meds from from it's
like a food truck but it's a caravan oh
it's a hunger and care of it really like
the movie [ __ ] discount so to be clear
by the way UV light kills I think it was
within 60 seconds if it's 95 degrees or
higher with 80% humidity alcohol
isopropyl alcohol works more effectively
than than bleach if it's airborne
particles UV light kills it very quickly
and then on a surface it kills it within
several hours depending I don't think
necessarily the overlay but this is
undeniable that's a good thing that also
means by the way that you are most
likely safer at a Florida beach then on
the El train in New York Oh
which is you know the elves of Chicago
right know there's a all trend in in New
York yes it comes in from Canarsie
Brooklyn I know this because state open
our sequin Brooklyn's fake news went to
the Brooklyn cultural center and I was
there I was one of the only white people
and I rode the El train and I'm ever
thinking like I'm there's a very strong
chance that I'm gonna get harmed this is
very much so because it's although it's
the farthest stop on the eltra last one
Rockaway Parkway you know what New
Yorkers fact-check my lawyer let me get
a win the El train goes out to Rockaway
Parkway and it sucks it's a subway and
then it's above ground and it's terrible
and this is but why are they allowing it
to be open in New York well because it's
essential yeah oh okay
but the beaches in Florida in a beach
town are not essential it's only
essential because the workers require
the subway to get to work what are you
saying that New Yorkers jobs are
essential and the guy who runs the tiki
hut in Florida it's his doesn't matter
yeah not essential income but I gotta
say a OC has been very consistent here
she doesn't want people working now she
didn't want people working at Amazon she
didn't want those I mean at the very
least she has been consistently
anti-american so you know they're the
little wins right now and you know
people are flipping and flopping but she
is just consistently communist you know
I realized when I'm in a rage spiral I
have less of a sense of humor because I
should be laughing but I was just angry
with you okay I wanted to throw this
wonderful girthy hand etched mug and see
if it left a lot of with Crowder shaped
in the river on your forehead
like Marv with the yeah heating iron I
feel like it does yes I feel like
president Trump could also be accused
based on CNN's reporting a little more
awesome pretty much if you slice
yourself in half and go out and sit in
the Sun you could be cured from kovat 19
I feel like that's what they would say
and be like he said we got to get it in
the body we'll just cut yourself open
right outside yeah but they would sound
anything they would count they'd be like
well that's what he said that's what he
said to do yeah and he was really just
talking about the circus brothers what
are the name of those brothers the
circus Bailey oh that's it by the way
we've talked about the Los Angeles
County study remember lassie Santa Clara
County right we said that at the high
high end it looks like the death rate is
0.5% and then for people who are healthy
who are average or middle-aged it could
be as low as point zero one that the
high high end I think we even said zero
point seven well guess what we have that
in Los Angeles now we have it in New
York City they did the antibody testing
and New York it's complete instead of
250,000 cases they're actually saying
now that it's closer to 2.7 million and
that means the death rate is 10 times
lower than expected their quote not mine
I calculated the numbers and I came up
with close to 0.7 yeah Cuomo said 0.5%
death rate in New York so now we have
three Santa Clara County we have Los
Angeles USC and New York the highest
possible mortality rate is 0.5 keep in
mind all of these protections were based
on what what 3 to 5 % death rate Wow and
in Italy it was trending at 10 percent
right yeah so we were thinking oh my god
every because everyone is old and
unproductive we're right but everybody
was scared because of Italy if you
remember come on what that's gonna
offend people what if a global economy
and already but it wasn't from them
aside from Geppetto hey noodle we're not
yeah thank you yeah thank you fireworks
and coronaviruses so you guys you're two
for three Chinese copyright and IP theft
these days is just making up for Marco
Polo stealing spaghetti oh gosh here we
go saying it you're oppressed by the
imperialist powers right throughout his
the problem is he didn't know just Marco
Polo
you couldn't the noodles there's a
intellectual property theft look I don't
sure would've had a good idea maybe it's
just if the problem is right now is CNN
is on and so by osmosis
we're all just prone to lying dumber as
well we're prone to saying what Donald
Trump told me to eat biscuits and
that'll cause you know kovat to go away
I mean what this is it's a ridiculous it
is hard not to be very angry because
because here's the thing it's so many
people are going about their lives when
you talk about a single mom at home
right now with kids if she turns on the
news and she goes hey I'm gonna kind of
figure out what's going on or she goes
well you know maybe I don't believe what
I heard on the news so I'm gonna go look
at the article and then they dig to
another article and they go to another
article and that all says the same thing
and they go now I gotta go feed my kids
breakfast and they walk away with this
panic and the false idea what's going on
right there and then they get told
there's no leadership nobody paying
attention and they ignore the fact that
this was a quote from a con from a
conference we're at a medical doctor and
another medical doctor we're talking to
the president about and instead they go
to CNN for real news and they click
through and they find themselves at
Chris chromos wife's blog selling
healing crystals Oh Christina quasi the
words Chris Cuomo will not leave my I
would never actually want to in any way
attack somebody's wife Christina Cuomo
is a public figure who in no way is
capitalizing on her husband's platform
to sell dangerous I don't think that's
true see of a new tech brian Stelter all
the time this is absolutely he is a
beautiful wife it doesn't apply to power
bottoms so hey while we're speaking
about the Sweden you guys know the
Sweden they didn't do a full lockdown
and right now the capital Stockholm is
expected to reach herd immunity in a few
weeks this is something that shouldn't
new to anybody they even thought this
was an idea originally in the UK that
they thought they might want to do the
problem with herd immunity is you have
to be all in not one foot in one foot
out but certainly if you look at the
numbers for Sweden they're not worse
than the rest of Europe certainly not as
bad as the UK or Belgium or France so
this does matter when people say oh the
social distancing worked well on a
second the numbers started declining
before social distancing would have
kicked in and you would have to look to
Sweden as well the point is there's a
lot of information that we don't have
something that we do have definitively
now is the death rate is less than 1/10
of what we were told and that's what all
the models were based on now if you
think that we should shut down the
economy that we has should have 22
million jobless claims as we've had now
in the previous weeks by the way did you
know one in five suicides is links to
unemployment so if you think that's
worthwhile for a 0.5% death rate
including 80 year olds and people who
are on see paps before they get kovat
then find you can make that decision but
you have to make the decision based on
the actual information and it is
remarkable to me that nobody is and I
will say this we'll move on to in a
second but it honestly either it like it
hurts my my soul my heart I thought
Donald Trump was a prick in the
primaries oh yeah yeah but the character
assassination that's taking place right
now it would be like us right now saying
hey not saying that you shouldn't shut
down that you shouldn't social distance
at all not saying that you shouldn't
wear mess it's not saying that you
shouldn't wash your hands but maybe this
has been overblown and someone goes out
and says steven crowder says don't wash
your hands and then one every day yeah
that something I didn't say it is it is
it's so sinister at this point you can't
claim ignorance we are beyond the point
of claiming ignorance no you have to
claim [ __ ] or instead read in it and
it's in a colossal waste of time when
every moment should be devoted to
something important
Donald Trump has to field questions
about did you say that we should inject
right right and why would you tell
Americans that we need to do that we
need you to be our leader like he's got
to field those questions instead of
what's going on with the virus net right
now what kind of treatments are we
coming out with I want to go back to
Sweden real quick though they did exact
never win this way you said go back
there mentally no yes I went there for a
wedding really incredible I can't go to
you every night killed well that's true
but in Sweden they did exactly what we
had talked about doing they made sure
that they protected the also it's [ __ ]
all of Europe is pure [ __ ] I don't know
if it's pure that's true it's adulterate
horn infested it's an adulterated [ __ ]
continent they make good wine in this
kidding I went to Ireland
but you couldn't I can't go to the UK or
France are you kidding me
here's why and I want you to go back to
Sweden but here's if people think that
I'm joking I don't know I can't you know
this this is not a joke I have no
defense if I'd go there there's enough
ammo on me because Bob
ah Spain and Mohammed where they can
jail me and unlike in the United States
no one can defend me right because free
speech isn't a thing if I go to Europe I
can walk off the plane be hauled off in
zip ties in a paddy wagon and you never
see me again because all of these
countries that we want to look until now
of course I think the house of cards has
come down with health care uh I don't
come back and for me that's enough to
say I hate your continent not the people
I think it's [ __ ] that you don't allow
that will discover kung-fu fighting
without being arrested from a karaoke
bar I don't like you we don't need you
that's why we left talk about Sweden
alright so sweet they did everything
that we said would be reasonable they
did social distancing nobody's
complaining about social distancing
right now nobody is complaining about
taking precautions washing your hands
making sure that you're not visiting
older people if you could potentially be
sick or even just cutting off those
visits it's a vacation everybody is
complaining about locking down the
economy and completely getting rid of
all of work in all of school they didn't
get rid of school either kids in high
school and below I think we're still
going to school as well yeah right they
did a phenomenal job at this and
everybody was like oh my gosh you're
gonna do just terrible you everybody's
gonna die well they have the same death
rate as people around them right
actually lower than low Belgium and
Denmark are half the size of their
country they have half the death rate
are not death rate per capita but half
the death number yeah per capita are
much lower than yeah exactly
couple weeks are gonna be good gonna
give a quick example if not if we're
gonna try and sell us some kind of new
disease preventative because your new
disease and then sell us the Cure that's
what you do and then do that racist
that's what you do bills Richmond not
Bill Gates get off my back hey cNN has
got a report on what Gerald just said
the quote would read Gerald supports
meatballs at IKEA has inventory shortage
also I'm locked in IKEA Anderson police
in help the arrows just lead to more
arrows what am I gonna do with 500 tea
candles awesome hey you know a
Transformers Leamas also contributed
very little by the way you know it's one
interesting thing is you this is
actually true if you were to go telling
us before this by the way
that's my concern says let me be honest
for a second are you okay no although
the rest of that was true
meatballs are a cure for not sure I do
is if you went to an embassy yeah or one
of these countries that has these laws
you could be arrested at the Embassy
yeah inside of the country know that
you're good so you know all these
invitations we get from Young Turks to
go speak at the you know UK embassy Wow
more sinister afoot okay so while we're
talking about this in the unemployment
and the shutdown of the economy in the
economy by the way not everything is
shut down it just comes down to what you
consider essential and now then people
working in New York City getting on
subways essential people who want to
work in Florida and be on beaches where
the UV light kills and sanitizes come
and not essential we understand it and
you wonder why people think you're
elitist well in let me present to you as
your people not agents lawyers would say
Exhibit B for [ __ ] only in America does
the president when the president
liberation does he mean go back to work
when we you know have this discussion
about going going back or reopening I
think a lot of people should just say no
we're not going back to that we're not
going back to working 70 hour weeks just
so that we could put food on the table
and not even feel any sort of semblance
of security in our lives first off she
looks like that she looks like the
blonde musician Muppet had dyed her hair
day the up angle for cameras is also not
very flattering and I know it's ad
hominem but it's okay just because I
have to stain for so that's all wrong by
the way that's all incorrect the average
American work week I don't have this in
front of me but I'm going by wrote I'm
sure we can bring this up you can go
look it up in a previous video is
30-something hours a week I think was 34
36 hours 34 70 hours by the way people
who say I work 80 hour work weeks all
the time they're lying it's very
difficult to do I've done it once or
twice but I regularly work 60-hour work
weeks people exaggerate all the time she
is lying she is I guarantee you
AOC has never never ever worked a 70
hour work week in her life Americans
working 70 hour work weeks are not
barely scraping by to put food on the
table when she says you know we want to
back go back no people don't want to go
back to their jobs actually most
Americans do when they talk about
Republicans pandering to the rich base
no Republicans and conservatives pander
to the gainfully employed base to people
who want to work Rosi wants people on
the public dole she wants people to be
hopeless she wants people to feel like
they are valueless and they are tools of
the government that they rely on the
government to sustain themselves she
doesn't actually have anything she
cannot relate to Americans who want to
work guess what sometimes work sucks but
I want to work I want to do this job I
would be miserable if I didn't work at
all now you do need a frame in your life
balance with work and your personal life
your family of course but if you want to
talk about being out of touch think
about this for a second Donald Trump the
man who was raised effectively a
billionaire okay has never gone a day in
his life without being in the lap of
luxury has more in common with the
average working-class American than aoc
from Westchester I believe that may be
wrong but I feel like saying it so I
hope you lose yeah I hope she gets taken
out easily from the political standpoint
right yeah but people want to go to work
they want to make a living they want to
be able to put food on the table that's
obvious but you know where you get a lot
of your self-worth from sometimes being
productive going out and writing a hard
day's work in and producing something
providing a service to somebody you get
a lot of your social interaction from
that you get a lot of your friend groups
from that it's a great thing to be able
to go and have a job if you sit on the
public dole for a long time like you
said there's health then there's health
risks for doing that right right because
you're not out interacting your suicide
rate goes up right out people yeah
that's important morally five suicides
are linked to unemployment is not a
surprise by the way we knew a guy in
Montreal so this was a good remember I
told you there was one wealthy family
let's not say the name there was one
wealthy family that I knew and it was
like oh my gosh they family makes
$100,000 like in Canada I couldn't
believe the Canadian dollars at us it
doesn't matter any dollars actually you
know probably would be under six figures
no yeah I don't know why I said it
didn't matter it's just because I'm
angry so my thoughts are fragmented but
one of the guys so their dad I played
hockey with the two sons their dad
killed himself because he lost his
and there's a there's actually there's
the Eaton Center for people in Montreal
who know this they call it I believe
they call it like the second city
because there's a whole underground city
mode you can literally never come above
ground and it goes like four or five
floors deep Wow
subterranean where they're shopping
there are food courts there are offices
so you get off so I would be across I
would be across the st. Lawrence River
yeah in on the South Shore of Illinois
and Greenfield Park st. Lambert I would
get in a subway I would get to downtown
Montreal like going from Brooklyn to
Manhattan and I could go anywhere that I
needed to in all of Montreal without
popping my head above ground and there
was a guy so when you think about the
subterranean right like a food court in
the Eaton Center so you're looking down
and you're looking down about four
storeys maybe five storeys it almost
looks like that's I think they shot a
scene in Blade Runner in Montreal for
not missed oh really I'll probably know
what I'm talking about that room was
like going up and you can sit up so this
is the Eaton Centre in Montreal this guy
lost his job and he jumped inside in the
Eaton Center oh wow and landed in the
food court but you know what is so
disturbing they looked at the security
camera footage and they saw him the
entire week pacing back and forth on
that top rail way really before jumping
because he knew that he was getting laid
off and then they looked into it and he
was trying to see what his insurance
would cover he tried to apply for other
jobs and then I think it was on the
fourth or fifth day he just tipped right
over and I say that that's anecdotal but
statistically that is verifiable that
suicides increase with unemployment I I
go to a therapist I go to an executive
in a sports psychologist and she's
talked about how this has been very very
difficult for a lot of people her
clientele is growing rapidly because
people are going out of their minds to
act like people who believe in reopening
the economy within this this multi-phase
program don't care about lives lost is
disingenuous and it's also to throw
people off the scent that they will
create more of a death toll yeah any of
one of the most harmful things for your
overall health is stress right you
imagine how stressed people are right
now that are just trying to get by
saying I can make it another week I
can't make it another month don't make
us get fact it's stress is bad but the
worst thing cyanide okay
do not exaggerate Gerald what a killer
and then it's the most ridiculous part
about it is you know it's never been a
ignore the health only focus on the
economy but the opposite argument is
being made every day like Samuel C is
making which is it or like what Rachel
Maddow said we can't think about
reopening we never should open anyone
talks about opening wants people to die
is excited for people to die when that's
not the case the case is it is a thorny
mess that we do need to have specific
ways that we open parts of the country
or parts of the issues in the
municipality right where they have the
subway and I get it and she's down there
breakfast every day driving their own
cars right can't make this stuff up you
want to know how I know they're
hypocritical as a kid I found out I was
a Republican at a very young age because
I did the Arthur show yeah and my dad
show me is like you would act it was
almost like Halloween candy read us okay
this is your check and then he would
sort of he would cash it and go this
goes to the government I don't think
they tax you under 18 we sure how it
works but he said they did you're over
18 I don't know about cam they took it
all for taxes then but he was like this
goes here this goes to healthcare this
and then you would say and this is what
you're left with what you guys yeah
these people these people are called
socialist in the United States are
called Democrats after Columbine and for
a long time hearing about guns and you
yeah yeah never fired a firearm until
his twenty years old because I was like
one person in a magical mystery handgun
of death that was in a closet that well
world war two relic room stick and
everyone was terrified of it but do you
know how you know that the left is
hypocritical there is one state one
state that I know of okay where you can
go and legally purchase a firearm
without any kind of any kind of
restriction at that point you don't need
a permit and as long as you pass that
background check as you would pass in
any other state you can walk out carry
it open or concealed forevermore and the
same state also doesn't have sales tax
on items like clothing and a lot of
luxury items mmm you know what state
that is Vermont [ __ ]
it's Vermont you want to tell me that
Bernie Sanders where he's championing
gun control why didn't he do anything no
one would bat an eye if he just said
okay you need a permit people like oh
yeah okay that's fine next thing they do
that and pretty much every other state
with the exception of like Arizona I
think there's maybe three states Vermont
purchase a firearm thank you put it on
your hip like your Rick Grimes or hide
it if you want to and I remember going
there every whatever you so I have to
calculate 15 percent sales tax because
that's what we had in Canada they're
like nah there's nothing like what I
don't have any tax on these crappy
carpenter jeans at Old Navy we're new no
two pairs with the same way size
resemble each other anyway nothing no
tax no sizes this is this is an extra
large yeah what's this extra large okay
there's a little garyun subway gern
pedophile rapist that guy federal prison
Jared oh by the way we do we know that
many of you are affected of course
during this quarantine which i think is
not going to be as long-lived for
everybody as people thought so there's a
silver there's a lot of silver lining
and hopefully when I'm Adam
you know I entertain you I deal with the
pain so you don't have to but we do want
to help people who are inconvenience and
so I think it's time to go to our
traffic report with our senior traffic
correspondent Tommy Finnegan
[Music]
all right Thomas Finnegan are you there
sir tell us what's going on this morning
I am here Stephen thank you for having
me
well after I crash-landed my helicopter
I was challenged to a duel by the local
tribes leader who goes by the name of
one I have successfully usurped his
authority okay but what do we have any
idea what's gonna be affecting people's
morning commute yeah no news on that but
I do have a new wife and her name is
okay well I guess we wish you the best
Thomas Finnegan is there anything else
thank you
[Music]
by the way I guess this is as good a
time as any to tell you that if you're
subscribed hit the notifications don't
mean a whole lot you can subscribe on
your phone Android Spotify for the
podcast and listen if you can't be
bothered to subscribe or hit on
notifications just check in every
weekday 8 p.m. Eastern there's a new
clip that goes up from the full show
right now you see what the full shows
are like from Mudd Club quarantine month
yeah if you want this show to continue
and you want to continue enjoying the
free clips on YouTube then please do
consider joining autotrader.com slush
mug Club quarantine you get $30 off yeah
hey if we get enough mug clubbers can we
get a new traffic guy well we may need
to then we had a big sponsor coming that
was a CBD sponsor but it turns out it's
a violation of YouTube's guidelines I
think all you potheads who think that
they're your friends not so much it's
just that feeling is there's no teach no
but that can't be a sponsor no that's
revenue I'll never get back
no never ever they're taking a lot from
you by the way that finding a guy he's
gonna want to stay on the payroll by the
way you can't let him go yeah I'm sure
he's a chief now he'll stop you no
matter chief doesn't pay as much as you
think anymore he has a new job
everything you know he was technically
he never actually ever did his old job
reported on but that was it gotta tell
you I was hoping the mood would improve
this morning not for me over they I've
heard if you throw that mug right at
audio aid it'll make you feel better
doing studies it depends yeah exactly
Nicole trials right there observational
studies yeah well you know there's
empirical evidence its demands they
don't throw that mug it Gerald maybe oh
no maybe I should ask Chris Cuomo his
wife sorry Christina Christina Christina
Cuomo hey Chris for short I don't know
I'm very serious lady in her own right I
thought it was crystal is it crystal
[Laughter]
healing crystal you're they align your
body's energy I don't know anything so
okay this is what was getting me so
upset this morning and I'm going to try
and calm how long is the clip
quarterblack game is 50 seconds oh
alright so for 30 seconds I won't be on
camera and I can practice my breathing
exercise to do a thing well show this
morning everywhere on CNN and I'm sure
we'll even see it as we go - oh my gosh
what is happening on CNN right now the
lady couldn't just like pick up her
stuff
it's like said his paper could I be no
no no that's Florence from Florence in
the machine has become a mayor since her
career if you're gonna be on that
solution and I mean that I use national
television in the loosest sense of the
word yeah she must just not be concerned
with putting away cardboard boxes
because of viewership yeah Tybee Island
is that place Heidi what decent idea oh
well we're some parent later of
apparently it's not tidy Island Martha
Stewart cheese okay so this morning on
CNN they were and medical experts saying
do not in any form drink bleach or Lysol
or inject it directly into the body
according to president Donald Trump's
directions this is everywhere right now
is trending on Twitter if you go to
Reddit politics which there just needs
to be a coup with conservatives going in
there see respectful voices no this is
all based on and you tell me if you see
it from the perm the president Trump
press brief or last night where he
talked about how sunlight UV rays kill
Co but he talked about which
sanitization products work and then was
turning to as you'll see medical experts
regarding some experimentation that they
might be doing you tell me if this
sounds like inject yourself with Lysol
supposing we hit the body with a
tremendous whether it's ultraviolet or
just very powerful light and I think you
said that has image ultraviolet test or
Parkland why I said supposing you
brought the light inside the body you
can which you can do either through the
skin or in some of the way and I think
you said you're gonna test that too
sounds interesting
right and then I see the disinfectant
where it knocks it out in a minute
one minute and is there a way we can do
something like that
by injection inside
or almost a cleaning because you see it
gets in the lungs and it does a
tremendous number well so it'd be
interesting to check that so that you're
gonna have to use medical doctors with
better chance it sounds interesting to
me oh sorry I was injecting Clorox into
my dick does it work per the president's
directly I was right I jumped the gun a
little bit there so uh did anyone hear
him say inject this by the way inject
Clorox now let me go through you
shouldn't have said the disinfectant
thing you should have separate his words
but he did do that with UV light now
this is important why cuz I've actually
been a little bit of a tiff with my wife
lately because really after I had knee
surgery right they used infrared light
they use it on my knee it's very typical
anyone out there if you ever done they
use this and it's it's actually approved
for certain therapies not a cure for
coronavirus I wanted to get an infrared
sauna but my wife was like well then
you'll be infertile Ana's trying to make
this argument actually it's not nearly
as hot as a Finnish sauna you can turn
it down you can get the benefit of
infrared light into your tissue without
actually having to get really hot and
she's not a fan so I can't do it okay
fine but the point here is we know that
it works right now run a search on
infrared light there's actually a
shortage on infrared saunas because
people for whatever reason think that it
helps with coronavirus I'm not saying
that it does right but it does raise the
body's temperature and it has been shown
in medical studies to help with immunity
so a lot of people have been looking
into that he said UV light or some other
powerful light force maybe we could well
guess what infrared light penetrates
deep into tissue he could be referring
to that or the non harmful UV rays he's
simply saying we know that this works
that it kills it if it's airborne would
there be a way to experiment with this
to see if it could help people and
they're talking about that that is
totally valid he didn't say go out in
the Sun and look like skin cancer lady
Sun bed lady because that's gonna kill
coronavirus he didn't say that he didn't
prescribe that and he was looking to
medical professionals by the way we're
talking about disinfectant in the body
do you know what chemotherapy is now
it's not Clorox it's not bleach it's not
Lysol but you are putting something in
your body that kills things and that's
why people get really sick this idea
that hey is there some kind of a
chemical that we could maybe extract to
clean out the lungs which is what he's
talking about were
well probably not but then the media
goes out and they use the brand name
Lysol Donald Trump said inject Lysol
what she didn't to the point that
lifestyle actually issued a statement
saying people look up the board at Lysol
in their political contributions because
that seems a little bit fishy to me
oh my god great cleaner but don't put it
inside your body and by the way like you
said he did look over to the doctor he
said I don't know they're looking into
these things right basically what he
said is we have found a weakness with
this virus and many other viruses how do
we translate that to something that can
go in the human body that won't kill us
but will kill the virus right actually
what he's saying he got no he could I
give him no leeway no benefit of the
doubt whatsoever in my comments at all
get gerald come it correct you you can
he didn't essentially say that he
actually was just asking yeah the
entirety of that exchange was saying
you're looking into these things right
yes are you looking into these things
that could disinfect was that a poor
choice of words
sure the guy who's a real estate mogul
and not a doctor is saying that we
resident to be assigned you know what he
did I understand more and after brought
up doctors saying well what's he kept
literally not only looking at the doctor
right but saying the word doctor while
talking to a doctor about hey are you
looking into these things yeah and you
know you would have to use a medical
doctor right and he goes I don't know at
the variant I don't know sounds
interesting to me and they do and by the
way they are they are consistently
researching light therapy and in some
cases it helps in some cases it doesn't
that's not quackery we'll get to that in
a second ran for it they use it in
incubators right infrared light therapy
they it's it is used in the medical I
don't know if that's what they're doing
but I guarantee you right now as they
explore all these options
they're probably looking into approved
non-invasive therapies if they could
potentially help her especially when you
consider that UV and infrared light are
both a part of the Rays that you feel
when you go out into the Sun and there
is a way to harness this with it being
beneficial and not harmful does it
benefit someone if they have corona
virus I don't know
president Trump doesn't know he said he
doesn't know could it cure it probably
not could it be beneficial as a
preventive maybe so these are
conversations that people should be
having and if he doesn't guess what they
say no answers from President Donald
Trump right now
virus continues to spread there's no
lead way and the character assassination
that takes place here right now going
out there in fact checking something he
never said is so upsetting well and I
would is probably gonna be what about
five minutes ten minutes until we get
the first story of somebody who's a
woman who poisons her husband I mean
accidentally gives her husband the wrong
thing oh by the way did you see that
Clark would we're now into lice on
Clorox he said inject it so the next
homicidal maniac who wants to get rid of
her husband says hey honey I ejected
myself I'm fine here's your's right
right well you know what else the guy I
remember the guy on the guy who took her
to chloroquine net yeah wife yeah he was
an engineer oh so really dumb right yeah
yeah in other words like an engineer
might have a question like hmm oh you're
having me drink fish tank allegedly
poisoned this lady who tried to divorce
him who has a history of mental health
disorders who didn't seem to suffer any
symptoms her nod off and said she drank
it because Donald Trump told us to and
her husband is an engineer drops dead
immediately the Lysol injection defense
is about to become Harold Baskin is
saying less severe yeah wouldn't have
gone that far though Donald Trump did
not push this by the way as though it
was a guaranteed cure he did not put and
there is a danger of course we all agree
in pushing quackery and unverified
medical absolutely which brings us to
Christopher Cuomo's wife Christina Cuomo
now again I want to be really clear none
of us would ever just attack someone's
wife because no they are a public figure
that wouldn't be right now Florida would
be crossing a line but Christina Cuomo
so you can forget about Chris Cuomo for
a second here christina is a lifestyle
blogger and health advocate who has the
pure purity what his name of the website
puris the pure the pure rest and then
see that's Christina Cuomo where she did
actually go through the Cuomo
chloroquine regimen so Christina Cuomo a
separate human being entity public
figure all in her own right that being
said Chris Cuomo's wife is an idiot
this is going out there while we're
talking about something that Donald
Trump never actually said she wrote a
whole blog post of their affair protocol
right uh one is she baths with Clorox to
combat metal in her system and to quote
oxygenate the cells well guess what the
Clorox website says and this wasn't
issued as a specific statement for Chris
promos wife this was long-standing issue
because people were making his claims
that are unverified for a very long time
now I know you can probably put Clorox
in a bath and be fine but her claim is
that she was doing it because it
oxygenates the cells that doesn't work
that's bullcrap do you know how I know
Clorox says don't do it and do you know
what else doesn't oxygenate cells oxygen
it actually doesn't work
hail oxygen they banned it and support
they realized that circulating oxygen
levels in the blood actually did not
increase there used to be this thing
called perfect water that was oxygenated
water no it doesn't work because your
body can limit it right what you if you
want to oxygenate your cells you need to
go into a hyperbaric chamber this is
what happens when people get is a cult
what's it called the bends and they come
up right that's what they use see Devers
you know what else can increase
oxygenation of the blood infrared light
therapy or set that's recognized by I
believe the FDA that's another form of
light right it's another form of light
may have mentioned you maybe you forgot
the word Clorox baths to oxygenate the
cells
oh my you know it also says at the very
end of that statement in the overlay
that we put up in the highlighted text
at the very bottom it says don't use
this in a bad that has not been approved
by the EPA we never recommend for you to
do that right ever right ever but
Christopher Christina Cuomo says that it
does you know do you add the crystals
yeah that's one post yeah crystal roof
healing crystals healing which if you're
wondering like has it been peer-reviewed
it's not been reviewed no peers probably
a crystal house somewhere where there
are a few Yelpers like guys didn't do
anything and the lady was really snooty
her husband kept coming out of the
basement like he was Jesus Christ
then shall I selfie she goes on to talk
about their regimen and she's in by the
way we know that christopherkrum we all
saw his video where he came out from the
basement and like he's been quarantined
there no we know that you were
threatening cyclists at to the police
reports christopher cuomo but let's get
back to your wife so she says that it's
all about how in our website it's all
about helping the immune system and
eliminating radiation because quote
we're all exposed to radiation cellphone
Wi-Fi and it agitates our cells i guess
we get more radiation the earth we
should get rid of daily basis from the
atmosphere and cosmic rays definitely
get away so she's getting on these
energy pads and she's talking about
these medicines and barks that are not
proven at all by the way and advocating
it as a regimen you cannot find Donald
trum advocating to people without the
care under the supervision of a doctor
advocating completely unproven methods
no the closest thing that you can find
in the media was furious about including
Christopher Cuomo by the way was Donald
Trump saying if you're if you're looking
at a ventilator
ask your doctor I would try the
chloroquine what do you have to lose
that's not nearly as bad as
electromagnetic Therapy pads and
crystals Clorox best don't forget the
bad war author ambassador to oxygenate
the south make a prediction someone's
gonna come out with an article that's
like Donald Trump's family owns seven
dollars in stock in the Sun to get
bigger and bigger
something shady and then joe biden said
can we create like a catapult it'll
block the Sun so that I plunged the
world into darkness all but guaranteeing
my who stopped actually a really bad
impression cuz he would never put those
many worries no anyway his on CNN this
morning like Jill Biden like where's Joe
he's an under-the-table asleep she looks
at the floor nowhere nowhere and she's
like kicking dope he gets sensory
overload too much we have him in a
flotation tank pretty much 24/7 until
it's time to come out and then we change
out the salt water yeah here's another
thing that Christine and Christopher
Cuomo's wife said she also says that
vitamin C in IV kills viruses like
Corona and she advises zinc now that
would be really clear action I want to
be clear about this vitamin C
intravenously has there is some and
determiner that shows that it can
benefit viruses and you can't take
enough of it orally right your body
doesn't actually use it you excrete it
so I don't want to see that everything
she's saying is completely unproven
right if we are using this standard that
they are trying to use with President
Donald Trump or any conservative then
absolutely you would have to throw this
out along with magnolia bark or whatever
else the hell it is that she started
like electric pads I never know what
half the stuff in China oh gosh we had
to go there you know I do think there
there look some folks are gonna go oh
you know the president should be held to
a higher standard of course she
shouldn't be you know touting electric
pads y'all go back and read the
transcript right it's an old video he's
talking to a doctor asking are you going
to be doing these kinds of studies to
check into these kinds of therapies
based on the fact that we know that
there are these analogies outside the
body is there some way for us to figure
this out also I've seen anecdotal
evidence and and studies about this drug
I wonder if your if you're at the very
end of your rope and you're about to be
put on a ventilator because you can't
breathe is it possible for a doctor to
try this yeah do any stands to gain
nothing as opposed to Christopher comas
wife who wants to sell you bedspreads so
I just want to be really clear here or
is that a conflict that's what if you
were to go to PubMed would say there's a
conflict of interest because this non
peer-reviewed study only include it only
included two subjects and it was funded
by Christopher Cuomo so you should take
it with a grain of salt also it's untrue
so she says that vitamin C in IV virus
so she goes to magnolia bark
electromagnetic
Clorox baths all the crystals are sold
on the website you know all the stuff
that doesn't really work that like
unilateral there are some supplements
that work some supplements that go has
nothing cures to run a virus but there
are some supplements out there that
could prove to be useful for people
right she recommends almost all of the
wrong ones I would encourage you to go
and look it up but vitamin C
specifically in like tumeric and stuff
which she talks about Ayurvedic medicine
Ayurvedic medicine really you can narrow
the case found in India it sounds
familiar though like those wouldn't that
be didn't someone say that might be a
problem raising authoritative
information but then we also talked
about removing information that is
problematic you know of course anything
that is medically unsubstantiated to
people saying like take vitamin C you
know take tumeric like those are all
will cure you those are the examples of
things that would be a violation of our
policy yeah so I expected to I mean a
student bread on YouTube but I expect
the purist blog to at least be removed
from search it should be so um and
that's all I have to say about that that
being said of course I wish Chris
Cuomo's wife the best in recovery is
dispensing dangerously bad medical
advice and killing people why do you not
care about lives that's really my main
concern here we have dancringe dancringe
dancringe and it will be probably about
10 minutes late and before that we have
one more story about Osama bin Laden
actually okay attempt on Obama to make
Biden president we'll talk about that
but first actually it's time to go to
our good friend correspondent pan tell
us tell stories
[Music]
so I see that a lot of you are still
looking all the negatives with his whole
kovat thing but look at the positives
look at the scientific breakthroughs I
don't you guys saw but in Italy in
Venice specifically since there's no
more people the Dolphins are back with
dolphins took over right
that's a discovery we had no idea that
dolphins much like the Germans were
disgusted by Italians I'm not saying
it's right for these dolphins to be
racist we would have never known had
this not happened you go to the Arab
world it's a religious time for them now
people are sad because the streets of
Mecca are empty right on the bright side
rapes are down 95 percent from last year
now domestic abuse is up in the region
but you know you win some you beat some
those are the rules of the kovat game
stay positive
[Music]
all right then thanks man tell us did
you notice that the Mounties were like
busting his door we have to get gonna be
gonna be not without my pen fellas just
putting them in a shawl across the road
we're gonna put them like the Nissan CEO
we're gonna put in some music boxes and
ship them transatlantic across the st.
Lawrence so here's another story that is
just it's just too funny to pass up did
you guys hear about the Osama bin Laden
had a plot to kill Barack Obama not for
gay of course I would fan of Brock Obama
but he's our sitting president of course
I would defend him because I'm Team
America especially when compared to you
know terrorists but the reason that
Osama bin Laden wanted to assassinate
Obama is
gut-busting ly funny because he thought
that bring that back up Joe Biden was so
ill-equipped to be President that it
would thrust the American public into
chaos so when people talk about the
Russians laying $3,000 on chase boards
you know for using nasty words about
Hillary Clinton just think about this
for a second public enemy number one
Osama bin Laden was going to pop his
head out of his cave to try and take out
our president just because he was so
supremely confident Joe Biden is out of
his mind and this is Joe Biden ten years
ago Joe Biden he is not a fine wine he
does not improve with no he's more like
an apple that's been put in a brown
paper bag but I think the Democrats knew
this and they have enacted his plan what
he was trying to do as a terrorist
attack they have done through the
nomination process well here's the thing
I'm not a Muslim but I think I might
have been wrong about all of us because
it seems like Osama bin Laden was
clairvoyant so maybe he was just
communicating with demons you know like
there's like Mohammed thought with yeah
Jim Satan and then lost Gabriel so maybe
that's what's happening at the sound a
lot differently maybe back then he saw a
vision or maybe in his hat was like see
it like then was the Islamic terrorist
like Harry Potter
Sears so maybe he saw back then what we
see now like this interaction I just had
to shoehorn this in between
Joba current presidential nominee Joe
Biden
arabia's presidential nominee Al Gore
watch what's happening we're not
organized and if we don't organize the
world who organizes it who organizes it
and so there's so much I think anyway
look one more question here is it too
late look at Gore's to address the
climate change and meaningful way
aggress aggress a face like I need to
get to a Swedish massage parlor but a
man named fan 2 ends quickly
I actually thought Al Gore was thinking
dang I kind of shot I should come back I
wish floored I didn't go increasingly
read I I do wonder do you think the
Russians are coming they're gonna come
and they're gonna be like man
we thought we were gonna you know mess
up America by getting Trump as president
that didn't work yeah so you know who
we're going for next Joe Biden Joe Bob I
guarantee you they want Joe so what
happened with Trump back then we talked
about the Russians is just no one gave
President Trump a shot remember the
night we did the election stream 99%
chance of Hillary's no way he was gonna
win so they wanted to undermine Hillary
Clinton the person who they thought
would be the sitting president either
way if Donald Trump was a heavy favorite
guarantee you they would have tried to
undermine Donald Trump read he was a
longshot and he won right and since they
just want to basically reach chaos on
the American public what better way than
to just I mean I don't even need to
create an ad set like on Twitter or
Facebook don't just take a clip and add
a million dollars to put it in
everyone's feed of Joe Biden and just
watch the magic I'm from what Joe Biden
is trying to do right now get in front
of you is all they would have to do to
destroy America they think in their
minds Joe Biden as president hey can we
show the screen real quick what screen
CNN oh the CNN what's going on hey look
at the look at the chyron at the bottom
it clips is 50,000 and then they look at
the number on the right inch away okay
that might be an inch and a half away
depending on size your screen guys they
can't even just look at their own screen
dangerously and look
acting thing again disinfectant
dangerously suggests injecting
disinfectant as treatment all day an
improvement from this morning where they
said Donald Trump says inject Lysol I am
offended by the fact that pence and
Trump have the same tie on yeah that was
pretty yeah a little bit rough you know
they both showed up and general Trump
was like [ __ ] damn you pencils like
that's okay president mr. president I
can just go without attack
no you look fantastic open collar you
know why this is the problem they're
unionized it's in there old school so
they can't change that ticker on the
right even though it's at fifty thousand
deaths on the bottom until the guy who
actually has vinyl scorecard flips it
over runs up to Edison Cooper and he
Pat's him on the button rules they're
not relying on their own source right me
I couldn't even just wait right they
were just like so excited they like guys
are you ready are you ready are you
ready do it do it is over fifty we're
ready
from Newsies clicking his heels in the
air yeah as opposed to Fox News is young
Christian Bale from Empire of the Sun
were just going yeah and then there are
planes all right so we actually have our
guest in the line which is really why
you guys tune in let's be honest course
he's a representative of course here in
the United States he's made a lot of us
proud recently yes new book is called
fortitude it's on a New York Times
bestseller list number five I believe
yesterday let's get it to number one you
know Mia love him he's a friend of the
show
Mr Dan Crenshaw how are you sir hey
Steven good to be with you man I'm doing
well how are you ah crappy
so um I do want to put my a call for
anyone it was I'm just really mad
because I injected Lysol this morning
and it ended well so I was following a
very specific name brand prescription
that I was told President Trump espouse
and just so you know it's not it's not
Cure you don't know that you're not a
scientist this is for people who haven't
seen it mr. krenshaw I do want to play a
clip because we've had you on the show
quite a bit but oh my gosh I think I'm
not a fan of Bill Maher maybe you two
have a friendly relationship but III
don't know I can't if you don't have
anything nice to say roll the clip
there are still people coming in from
China he only stopped foreign national
okay let me address that because I know
that's that's the people are saying
right now but the reality is it was
about 40,000 people came in after that
these are US citizens and green card
holders and passport holders being
repatriated US citizens so you have to
make the argument then that that we
shouldn't allow them in and it sounds to
me like you're fully agreeing with
President Trump on this when everybody
else disagreed with them and if you're
saying that you wish extreme okay fine
you apparently had the foresight back
then but when nobody else did okay okay
okay okay please get this book to number
one because I want you to go back on so
I have been present and known quite a
few people who've been there for Bill
Maher's tapings and a lot of it like
there's a crowd animator at most
late-night shows and then at Bill Maher
it's like you better clap or you are out
of here threat and he uses that power of
the audience we've never seen Bill Maher
performed this poorly he usually
portrays himself as a genius let me ask
you did you do you think that it helped
you that you were both on equal footing
as opposed to being in his studio with
his audience did that embolden you equal
footing is is always good I've never
been in his studio with his audience
I've got nothing to compare with you
know the conversation could have gone
totally differently if it was about a
different topic also the reality is on
this particular topic we have all the
evidence on our side right and they
don't so they're there they're at a
total disadvantage I do think Bill
Maher's a smart guy oh you know I do and
I do have some respect for him he does a
lot of things that like I really don't
like either I mean I have the same
opinions but but he no no I don't have
much respect for anything smart but I
don't have much respect for him so I
want to make sure that you're not tarred
and feathered because of my
and respect yes yeah I mean I just you
know I try to give everybody not
everybody but a lot of people the most
benefit I can yeah
and he takes I I appreciate anybody who
who goes after their own progressive
left-wing vestrum with left-wingers did
to the extent that he does and you know
I like like I told him on the show and I
meant it I do see him as this as a
liberal not a leftist and I think
there's a difference and I think he's
wrong on almost everything he says yeah
but but but at least he's willing to
debate it and bring somebody like me on
sure and you know present his facts the
best way he can and allow me to present
mine so yes respect that being said I
think that you have a skewed view
because right this this was a run in its
entirety and again often what happens in
his studio is he cuts the parts that he
doesn't like that's the problem we've
actually only ever edited in the history
of the show two interviews and that was
by one was by request and the other one
was because the guy was on drugs and
didn't remember it and we thought well
it wouldn't be fair to run this outside
of that we never change it we let the
cards fall where they may
it was already lying it's no secret and
I and I love Artie Lange and I didn't
want him to get in trouble this was
before you know he's sober now so that's
a good thing we can celebrate it but um
so your experience is more of an even
debate that doesn't happen in a studio
that being said my primary gripe with
him is that he's a painfully unfunny and
I don't have that was like Jon Stewart
even Stephen Colbert you know Bill
Maher's punchline is right right and
someone with an applause sign and so
when you take that away from the
equation I mean you were daddy yeah I
just I don't know what it's like that to
have the audience there I don't know
that it would have changed all that much
it kind of depends on your personality
to an extent I'm a bit emboldened by by
even more adversaries right and and
they're not they're not all that
distracting to me you know you you put a
lot of effort in preparation into any
interview you kind of know what the
topics are gonna be again I'm a they're
fair like they say hey we're gonna talk
about this stuff when I can tell you
what our questions are where I could
tell you what angle were coming at it
from you're gonna generally tell you
what we're talking about so
you know even if they hadn't told me
that of course I know it's going to be
about Trump having blood on his hands
right like the course I know that yeah
because that's what everybody is talking
about all the time during that week
notice it stopped notice that that line
that narrative hasn't yes is bubbled up
a whole lot recently I think I think it
was it was so thoroughly debunked and
the Washington Post tried to do a fact
check on me they did their best
there was no fact-checking in there just
quibbling and and then guy Benson tower
friend wrote it wrote a counter piece to
that oh he's not my friend I hate him
actually in in this is what's funny is I
swear this is the true story guy Benson
Hill Hill he won't confirm this very
nice guy always had good I used to do
his show all the time I was living with
the Booker for redeye in Chelsea New
York which is I was the only straight
man for four straight blocks I did at
this point guy Benson was out of the
closet and so we were on a Fox panel
together and I was like right you'd have
to pay money for hotel er we couldn't
stand the couch to go thank you I'm
pretty sure at the time he probably
thought I was a gay gay roommate in
Chelsea right afterwards he was like it
came out of the classes like I'll let
you're sleeping in my gosh my door
didn't ever lock so no I love guy Benson
and if I were you mr. krenshaw do you
prefer representative Crenshaw mr.
Crenshaw Danny
hmm Dan something I do appreciate about
you that you just said all kidding aside
as you said you know you prepare for the
interviews there are some people in the
conservative movement and frankly I'm
smart enough but I always over prepare
so for example if we do it change my
mind or something like that which
quarter black haired audio wait jailed
you know it can be four or five hours
and anyone who comes up I will spend
each hour of change my mind averages out
to about ten hours of prep and there are
a lot of people who take pride in saying
I don't prepare I'm just that good and I
think that you're obviously very smart
you're a sharp guy
but you telling people that you take it
seriously and prepare that's not always
the most popular
Marketing angle and does it frustrate
you when you see other people who you
know prepare thoroughly but they act
like it comes naturally Wow I've really
thought about that I don't really
believe anybody that's just I mean
honestly if they are if they are genuine
I always see is the outcome right so if
you're genuinely good at debate and
you've anticipated counter arguments and
you've got a list of facts then clearly
you've prepared now maybe you've
memorized it faster than then somebody
else did maybe it only took you 30
minutes right maybe you do this so often
that really you didn't prepare right
there's plenty of heated debates that I
go into that I honestly don't prepare
for but that doesn't mean I haven't been
preparing for years right yeah exactly
you're living the life braces it yeah
right
right so I don't know I'm not I'm not
even I haven't really thought about that
too much no I think it's a nice I think
it's valuable I think young people who
look up to you and there are a lot of
people who look up to you hearings
sometimes people think like oh my hero
or someone I admire they and I'm not
saying you're my hero I like you but you
know let's hold back the reins a little
bit but for some people that may be the
case and it's good for them to see like
oh she takes this he prepares he
understands that he can be caught
flat-footed that makes it that makes it
more accessible than humility
yeah I provide and you know chapter two
is it's called who is your hero and and
it's a question and you would answer it
dan Crenshaw and Bill Maher would answer
well you would scratch out your own
right daddy yeah yeah you have to
understand I never and my lawyer half
agent Larry bill Richman has a question
for you but I never made it past the
screener with Bill Ryan I spoke on the
phone with a screener
and they asked me I remember they were
this was when the Russia thing was going
on and I said well what do you want to
talk about I said well I don't know what
do you want to talk about and they said
well you have to I said well I just
stopped Beauty in the Beast last night
and I thought it was pretty funny that
in colonial France they had black
royalty in the wig and white face like
if we're talking about hashtag Oscars so
white you know can't you chalk this up
as a win and she goes so you want to
come on a political show and talk about
beating the Beast I said no I just told
you what pissed me off yesterday I saw
the film what do you want to talk about
and she goes Russia as I said okay
listen what do you got aside from
conjecture and she said we'll call you
back I'm not I'm not as smart as the
folks who make it on the show I can't
hold a candle to the Essie cups and the
world I would love to see you and Bill
hang out I think it'd be hilarious but
so so yeah I do think preparations
important I do talk about that in my
book quite a bit and in a serious way I
did bring up that chapter called who is
your hero because you have to be when
you look up to people it shouldn't be a
person because somebody will always
disappoint you right and but you should
look up to attributes and you should you
know my my debate the the guy that I
look up to as a debater who's always
anticipating the arguments and knows how
to frame the argument Gallagher can
probably guess and Shapero framing the
argument is incredibly important um but
the way I framed the argument for bills
show was this like are you it's a simple
question or are you trying to make Trump
look bad are you trying to get to the
truth right because there's two
different answers there yeah and and I
think I think I think the best way to
debate the left oftentimes is to expose
what they're doing in that moment and so
so here's an example right like lately
we've been debating whose fault it was
that the small business funding got
delayed well the Democrats will claim
that there that they are on a moral high
ground because they all they wanted to
do is add more money to it right and so
and so they fought for that and they're
they're fighters for the American people
and they're fighters for our hospitals
and the testing that here's here's the
thing they're they're fighting for money
that doesn't need to be replenished
right you know the funding and the that
we've already allocated is not even
close to being spent yet should have
spent the small business we should have
refund it's a small business funding
over a week ago and then figure it out
you know how to spend the rest of the
money but but here's how to frame that
argument and expose what they're doing
they're attaching the size of their
heart to dollar sign right so just say
that right like that's that's an
important they're attaching the size of
their heart to dollar signs from
somebody else's pocket it's not their
dollar exactly that's something that
you'll often miss and I was
listen I don't consider myself a skilled
debater at all but the one thing that
I've always talked about and this was a
book that I pitched funny enough to
conservative publishers backgrounds at
Fox News it became changed my mind
and they said this isn't gonna work the
Obama blueprint was a big book to like
if you haven't a doomsday Obama thing
that'll sell but this won't work to try
to convince people to your way of
thinking and I always said yeah this is
before social justice warrior was a term
this is before snowflake was a term so I
referred to them as sort of I think I
refer to them as modern leftist
progressives and the American idiots
meaning that sort of green day use that
against conservatives and I meant
American idiots people who are liberal
by default people who watch TV who tune
in to CNN who every radio show they
listen to every band they like tells
them to be left-wing and I said there
are two different approaches you need to
change the mind of these people these
sort of ignorant Americans who've taken
this position by default and that's
where you take an approach use a
Socratic method have them walk through
their own arguments that's usually most
productive someone like a Bill Maher and
Nancy Pelosi like you're saying what you
have to do is to highlight what they're
saying make an example of them so that
then you can convince the people who've
taken the position by default and
identifying the two different kinds of
people with whom you're speaking is I
think a very important skill set and I
think you handled it very well that's it
that's a great point yeah well because
the insight you're not going to convince
Bill on his show to see your way but
that's not the purpose of the show the
purpose is to do is to have a debate for
an audience and and convince other
people that way what you do would change
your mind is really great and I love
that you put a lot of preparation into
it you have to because you have to
anticipate every angle that somebody's
going to come from right every personal
experience that they might bring up and
and I think you do a good job of
anticipating that it also helps when
you're trying to support an argument
that you've got a lot of evidence I buy
for and I think it's important to have
those because I guarantee you that if
Bill Maher and I were to sit down and
talk or for example when we had we've
had mayor's in the show and Naomi Wolf
it's more hostile in the sense that when
someone is coming on saying I'm wrong
well listen I'm gonna match the
intensity so it's important for me for
people to see me speaking in a very
civil respectful way and trying to
convince people bring them to my way of
thinking so they understand the
difference between that and handling
what is effectively a character assault
because I'm not always going to be meek
my half the
did you have a question there I did yeah
so a representative thanks so much for
being on the show I'm one of the
questions I have right now is we know
that there's a lot of different counties
and states that are opening taking some
measure approaches to try and get people
back to work
allow the economy to partially restart
you know are there any particular
thoughts you have about those counties
and is there any part about your book
fortitude that you think speaks to
what's going on right now and the kind
of debates we're having over the
controversial topic of letting some
people safely go back to work yes
definitely so what I talk about a lot in
the book it's a prevalent theme
throughout which is personal
responsibility owning your own destiny
and and and I make a very strong
argument against this idea of victimhood
culture where you actually remove agency
from people's ability are from people
and remove their ability to control
their own lives when you tell somebody
your victim that's effectively what
you're doing or disempowering them this
is pretty applicable to how we open up
our society we have to trust the
American people to make the right
decisions to live with this sense of
duty another thing I talk about in the
book is is the fact that the
government's job is to protect your
rights but there is an exchange there an
exchange of citizenship an exchange to
live responsibly in to live dutifully
and morally we don't talk about that
enough we don't talk about the idea of
citizenship and doing the right thing
and that is more important than ever as
we reopen the economy it's just it's you
have to trust people and I'm I'm going
against our County judge here in in
Harris County because she wasn't she
gave a directive that all too sensible
that we suggest that we wear masks in
public that's fine but then out at a
thousand dollar fine if you don't do it
right that's not quite right you know
and it's just totally unnecessary allow
Americans to do the right thing you know
we were already socially distancing
before it was it was a directive from
the top down
and we can do this to let businesses
figure it out okay let let businesses
figure out how to restructure their
office space or their restaurant space
so that we can get back to normalcy
there is no choice but to return to some
sense in
new normal there's no choice right and
in this false dichotomy between staying
home forever and and letting people die
that's that's a false choice it's not
true never has been only political
opportunists are making it sound like
that it disgusts me and but it's up to
gets back to that normal new normal we
have to act like good Americans and I'll
say this last thing one you know talking
about the Harvard that took the money
but returned it and the shake Shack's
that took a month with money but
returned it if you're a business out
there that whose revenue hasn't really
changed you know shame on you for for
taking the small business loans that
we're giving out it's very hard from a
policy perspective to put proper limits
on those it's extremely difficult
because if as soon as you do you start
making it even harder for the smaller
but then the problem also you know I
think we also know the problem he comes
like John Stossel has talked about this
he had some kind of a federal grant
subsidy where his home built on stilts
effectively in the ocean washed away
like two times because I know that some
people say I'm a hypocrite for taking
the state funding but I'd be an idiot
not to and there is a problem where if
small businesses are still even
operating on an honest profit margin
well if they don't take the loans that
are available they're going to be
competing with bigger businesses that
are and they'll fall further behind yeah
and totally get it but on American and
they should be ashamed of themselves
a period full stop so so when I go to
the mill I've read about this in my book
too when I got out of the military and
this is this this feeds into the
victimhood culture and there's a reason
why when I got in the military I was
eligible for Social Security disability
insurance I was actually they actually
promoted it in the military like hey not
only are you getting medically retired
because you're injured or something's
wrong with you
but what happened get out that's gonna
be a highlight okay startling continue
yeah they were promoting Social Security
yeah I know this uh yeah so it blew my
mind this was after I got my you know I
blown out huh and so the others
make him feel man it was yeah in case
you were wondering what happened but but
I bet
but in that classroom full of other
other Navy sailors I was honestly
wondering what had happened every single
person in there was looked fine from the
outside at least nobody had been in
combat this were not a bunch of fellow
special operators by any means this was
not army infantry or Marine Corps none
of that everybody was getting medically
retired for some reason there's a lot of
reasons you can get medically retired or
just choose to go through the medical
requirement process yeah and the
government will take care of you
afterwards I think I believe generously
some might disagree with me I believe it
it's very generous yeah but to also get
Social Security disability insurance
which most Americans believe is for
Americans that are so disabled they
can't work right so they need SSDI I
could have gotten up to two thousand
dollars extra a month especially after I
got out and I wasn't full-time working
remember I went back to school mm-hmm I
didn't take it I refused to use to to to
apply for that I could have and buy
economic sense and buy it by the
straight economic sense that you're
describing and that a lot of businesses
are using to justify taking money that
they don't need I could have taken that
I refused because that's not who I want
to be and this goes into the
conversation about who your heroes are
right in what we should applaud in
America yeah I was moreso just pointing
out the issue that in this case it's in
this case it's appropriate because the
government stepped in and said we're
gonna effectively put you out of
business right they said don't don't be
a patron in this business anymore don't
support so this is different from
stimulus yeah yeah but my point is that
this is what ends up happening when the
government let's say more so it would be
more appropriate with the the stimulus
under the Obama era presidency where
you're effectively picking winners and
losers then everyone says like well if I
have to to compete it becomes like the
steroid argument and it's not a good
thing that's all we just should have
government involved as little as
possible final question I know you have
to go regarding your book fortitude
which is available everywhere books are
sold if you can find a bookstore anymore
but certainly digitally on Amazon you
talk about in the book like how to find
strength and fortitude and obviously
it's reminiscent of Jocko quite a bit
who's been on this show and I think it's
a message that's it's very much needed
how would you respond to this claim it's
going out quite a bit
that generation Z believe they've lived
their entire lives in crisis and so
they've lost hope I mean this is front
page at a lot of different news outlets
as though they've had it worse than any
generation before them and then when
polled they are more defeated and
hopeless and and that mindset to me is
frankly very scary as they enter the
workforce yeah you know the best
reference for this phenomenon with Gen Z
is as Jonathan Heights book the coddling
of the American mind I referenced that
book quite a bit in my book my book is a
set of solutions to the problem I'm not
diagnosing the problem itself I
reference good authors that have done so
and coddling of the American mind I
think is the premier place to look if
you're looking for why Gen Z is that way
and there's a lot of reasons college
campuses basically reinforcing these bad
ideas that your feelings actually matter
and they matter but like the feelings
that make you right right like like over
reason and over logic and the you know
the the coddling that has occurred both
on campuses and in the household you
know there's there's good data on this
to show that Gen Z was only allowed to
leave the house to go to a friend's
house like much later in life than say
even Millennials or or Gen Xers and
really I can say - what's really scary
though so is they have a legitimate
gripe that they're entering a more
competitive workforce than previous
generations like that is something that
now it is hyper specialized so you have
a generation and I would say more so
Millennials and Generation Z it seems
like they might actually be a little bit
better some of the stats that we're
seeing but um they are being coddled
growing up and then being thrust into a
hyper-competitive exponentially evolving
workplace and that seems like a recipe
for disaster because there is validity
to them going like I don't know how me
to do this yeah and there is ability
validity just like when the Millennials
have complaints about basically
graduating into a financial crisis you
know I get it there's some validity to
these issues very simple iddah t-to the
complaints that housing is more
expensive health care is more expensive
and college is more expensive relative
to past generations it is okay
everything else though is much better
does it cancel each other out I'm not so
sure can you can you move to a place
where housing is G
yeah you can't Millennials like to live
in places where housing is more
expensive also better jobs are there so
you know I get it
there there there are pressures that we
that we do have to I think acknowledge
and and in Jen's II I think we have to
acknowledge to that yes they are they
are starting their early careers right
now in the midst of this crisis I do
think we bounce back from this rather
quickly and so that would be my message
of hope to them yeah I mean message of
hope is imagine France surrendering and
going like oh pretty much all of Europe
is lost except for one guy Churchill
putting up a fight and we have a choice
between communism or fascism I think
that probably would be a little bit
scarier than a according to Cuomo the
highest estimate now is a 0.5% death
rate every light life lost matters but
it's not the depths of despair and
hopelessness for every generation Z
American okay the book is fortitude
mister representative Dan Crenshaw I
appreciate you being here brother stay
well and let us know next time you're on
on bill maher show well thank you to be
with you be well all right hang up on me
so smug so very very helpful and the
book is fortitude it's available
anywhere books yeah are available
frankly I let's get to a couple of chats
and then let's play this out can I point
out with something very quickly since we
were livestream bitching about the
numbers being off on CNN
yeah if now corrected it it ah their
sources themselves yeah like well
ordered ourselves they used to be Johns
Hopkins only down there these sorts
another like no no no we're better than
Johns Hopkins wait and why do they have
the the expert right now staring at the
Ark of the Covenant let's read a couple
of chat yeah the promo code is
quarantine $30 off letter of credit calm
slash Mont Club and you'll be able to
check with us as well because YouTube
pays us not go ahead we've got one here
good morning all I joined mug Club today
I'm a truck driver and enjoy listening
to you guys a Spotify I was wondering if
there is any way to hold the press
accountable either legally
or otherwise for their negligence or
lies lies like your name your stage name
Mickey Fayette this one probably got a
bill but I think I know the answer
so there's a very very high standard
when it comes to going after new sources
as you can imagine they've lobbied a
long time to make sure that the
precedent is such that unless that you
are intentionally or maliciously going
after someone with fake information
which again requires might have a
mindset right but certainly there's a
pattern a lot of what you get for intent
and maliciousness yes what we call mens
rea or the mind and if you have done
enough acts then you may be able to
interpret that this is my so it's gonna
be real hard you know who actually has
the most power don't click on CN n yeah
yeah don't go to the sources that you
don't like don't go to the nearest yeah
don't go to the purest unless you really
really need an elected crazy-ass witch
doctor [ __ ] calm that's my preferred
holistic natural advice same advice all
right final check it John H question for
everyone in your opinion what is the
worst thing that the Democrats have done
or said since Trump became a president
oh that's oh a lot of options I think
just I think the overarching idea is
that Donald Trump wants to kill
Americans when it's repealing the
Obamacare laws that weren't really
working they're saying that when he
wants to reopen the economy in a three
or four phase program they say it's what
I didn't take your pick when he has a
meeting with kim jeong-hoon
ever they always like he doesn't care
about the lives of Americans and I think
when you look at again his comments and
when he tries to the reason he's doing
the press briefings is because he wants
to speak directly to the American people
right and when he does that he tends to
actually register better with the
American people his poll numbers of when
Cortes is speaking directly from her
webcam people go oh someone's primary so
the idea that Donald Trump and of course
all conservatives be aware by the way
every attack on Donald Trump even if you
didn't support him
me in the primaries I had someone else
an attack on him is really an attack by
proxy and all conservatives that's what
they're trying to do right now they're
trying to say to Republicans if it
weren't Donald Trump if we're Rand Paul
if it were Carly Fiorina if it were Ted
Cruz they'd be saying the same thing you
don't care about lives unless you
support our policy like making sure the
stimulus sends money to Planned
Parenthood's so that to me is really
probably the worst because listen I even
think I say kind of tongue-in-cheek when
I say why don't you care about the lives
lost by keeping the economy shut down
because one in five suicides are related
to unemployment I don't think that they
want Americans to die I just think
they're being disingenuous and their
policies will absolutely verifiably
result in more deaths than a systemic
opening of the economy in a responsibly
phased program yeah I would say Russia
real quick just because basically
spending essentially billions of dollars
trying to undermine his presidency from
the get-go so that everything he says
later is through the lens of a puppet
president whose illegitimate who's being
controlled by somebody else right I
think the worst thing they said is
presumptive nominee Jill Biden I might
argue that's the best thing because it's
gonna be hilarious when we get to
debates but why do you want more
Americans to die by making Joe Biden the
president you have any idea what will
happen the cash arrives forget to pay
the debt belt all right money who's that
what heart or take out our core getting
a massage thank you guys we are going to
see you Monday morning with more good
morning mug Club and then of course
shows every night in the live stream on
Thursday with the press briefing
followed by live fact-checking of CNN
okay through their prime time clock it's
gonna be tough appreciate it lot of
credit calm /mo clip promo code
quarantine three dollars off see you
next week
[Music]